you've said that elton john was this
huge influence on you now you're at the
point where elton john you're calling
him up and talking to him what is it
like to be friends with elton john i
mean to actually have a friendship with
the guy well i'm getting less less and
less nervous you know it's like
it's the thing about elton john is like
if he's your hero like he may be for
some of you listening like the thing is
he's like every single thing that you
hope he would be
in that and that includes
great at dirty jokes you know like
curses every third word but like he's
also really upstanding and moral he's
got a lot of opinions he's an
encyclopedia for music and he's really
uh empathetic you know
he feels for other people and he's quick
to tears quick to laughter quick to all
the things that make us alive
and um man it's just like wow i picked a
good one you know so when you were
searching for a name for your book and
he says to you brandy you should call
your book rug muncher
that was the most that was the most
benign one i could tell you
i mean
you didn't get like here you've written
this book you probably said to elton hey
i've written this book and you're having
this heavy discussion with him and he
says that that's that's the kind of guy
he is right i mean oh yeah
yeah yeah and there's a whole song that
accompanies it i don't remember it but
it's
yeah he is really good fun he makes me
really laugh at myself he's vile
yeah
[Laughter]
as a kid when you first started singing
you entered like an elton john you had
to dress up as elton john all these
contests kind of bordered on pageantry
right and all these little girls would
dress up with their updos and their
gowns and their sequins and they would
always do whitney or celine and um
or reba if they were country
and um
i tried it for a while i did i did all
of them all the whitney and the celine
things but i never did the updos or the
whole the dresses or anything and then
and then one time um i convinced my mom
to let me dr dress up in like a white
suit
a new honky cat
yeah such an eccentric song
you know for like a 12 year old whatever
how old i was to do it but she made me
like big
feathered sunglasses out of pipe
cleaners and
um into
boat shoes that said e and j on each
foot with like sequins and stuff yeah
she was very supportive
yeah yeah that was cool that was a big
moment actually